5 grilles d'exposition par artiste c'est
ce que propose le salon d'automne
d'andrésy le but diffuser plus largement
l'univers des peintres et sculpteurs
présente ils ont été sélectionnés
scrupuleusement parmi différents salons
d'île de france ces différents talents
différents talents parce qu'il ya
plusieurs réécritures artistique
alors vous avez de l'huile de
l'aquarelle du pastel
vous avez des différentes techniques
c'est assez exceptionnel dans la région
d'avoir 5 5 panneaux pour nous tous
seuls est ce que ça représente quand
même des univers de chacun il y en a
vraiment le temps de rentrer en fait
dans chaque univers venus d'un peu
partout de la france mais aussi
d'andrésy ces artistes utilisent tout un
panel de techniques en hiver il est il
assez variés parce que ça dépend en fin
de compte des émotions je suis très axé
sur tout ce qui se passe dans
l'actualité il ya beaucoup de choses et
j'essaie de faire sortir ça de manière
poétique on va dire suffit il hip hop
puis voyez derrière
qui en fait a été fait donc à
l'acrylique avec beaucoup de couleurs en
fait avec des gratte et au couteau et
en fait je
ça représente en fait mon travail actuel
puisque le bon jeu travaillant avec ce
système de grades ajustements sur toile
ce salon organisé par l'amicale des
beaux-arts d'andrésy et fort de plus de
45 ans d'existence il a comme objectif
principal de promouvoir l'art et de
donner une visibilité aux artistes
présents à l'art c'est comme le théâtre
c'est comme le cinéma la peinture la
sculpture qui est un art un que beaucoup
de gens apprécient et puis on est revenu
à une période pendant ces deux ans on
était très difficile mais ça redonne du
plaisir le contact avec les les passants
nous permette vraiment d'avoir un un
regard sur notre travail c'est aussi la
raison pour laquelle en exposant les
artistes s'y posent c'est pour permettre
d'avoir effectivement une belle
visibilité vous pouvez encore voter pour
votre peinture et sculpture préféré
jusqu'au 31 octobre date à laquelle un
prix du public sera remis au gagnant